The most commonly used security protocol across the web is by far SSL.
The most commonly used security protocol across the web is by far SSL slash TLS. I mean any time you
connect to a secure server to buy things across Amazon for example or you're doing your web banking
or you're connecting to any website where any level of security is required. Chances are you're
going to use SSL slash TLS to do this with and as you'll see this is how we create a very secure
connection between any browser and it doesn't matter where that browser is you could be at home
you could be at work you could be at Starbucks you could be in Bora Bora somewhere at a hotel
and if you want to create a very secure connection between that browser wherever you are
and a secure server at the other end it's SSL and TLS that will do it for you so what we're going to do
here is we're going to go through the actual steps of how SSL creates that secure connection
and we're going to summarize it in four easy steps what's important for you is not to memorize
the four steps but to have a complete understanding of how those steps actually work together to
ultimately create that secure connection that is established using SSL and TLS now the first
thing that we have to understand is what's the difference between SSL and TLS because there's a
lot of confusion that exists in the industry related to this well just think of it this way TLS
is the latest version of SSL in fact when they took SSL version three and decided to make some
really minor improvements to it they decided to rename it altogether to something called TLS
and the reason they did that is to remove confusion that existed as to where SSL runs according to
the OSI model layers a lot of people wrongly thought that SSL stood for secure session layer it does
not in fact the second S is for socket SSL stands for secure socket layer but a lot of people
mistakenly thought that it ran at the session layer it does not it is a transport layer security
protocol and so to remove that confusion the industry decided to rename it altogether so instead
of calling it SSL version four they decided to rename it to something that would eliminate that
confusion altogether TLS transport layer security and I think you know just think of it as the
latest version of SSL but the protocol itself is still called SSL by many people because it still
is the SSL protocols just the latest versions of it is called TLS now let's say you wanted to buy
something at Amazon dot com so we'll use that as an example so you type in into your favorite
browser www.amazon dot com now as soon as you make a connection to the Amazon servers both the
server and your browser which is referred to as the client will recognize that a secure connection
is required and that will activate the capabilities of SSL slash TLS now the first thing that happens
here in step number one is that the client you are referred to as the client that's the browser
the browser the client will send what's called a client hello message to the server all that's
meant to do is allow the server to understand that it can talk to you in other words you're using a
version of a browser that it understands you're using a version of SSL that it understands so
that step number one called the client hello message is simply allowing the server to say okay
I can understand you we can talk now in step two the same thing has to happen the other way
and so what happens in this step is the server will send you the client a server hello message to
allow you to say okay I can understand you as well we can talk in both directions but very
importantly what happens in this step as well when you're receiving that server hello message the
server will also send you its certificate and you'll remember from previous modules that a
certificate will contain the public key of in this case amazon dot com so when you receive that
certificate that certificate will contain amazon's public key but that entire certificate will
have been signed or encrypted in the certificate authorities private key so what you're receiving
is a certificate that contains amazon's public key but that certificate has been issued by a
certificate authority let's use vericine as an example now as soon as you receive that certificate
along with the server hello message your browser has the ability to look at that certificate and
say oh this is a vericine certificate because one of the fields on that certificate is issuer ID
which identifies the certificate authority that created that certificate in the first place
so now in step number three your browser understands that it's a vericine certificate goes into
its functionality and grabs guess what vericine's public key that's built into your browser functionality
and decrypts that certificate using vericine's public key and if it decrypts properly you are not
going to see a pop-up that says something is wrong with the certificate if you don't see a pop-up
that certificate was decrypted properly but now what you can do as a result of that two things have
actually happened first of all you've authenticated that you have connected to amazon.com and not some
other sketchy website pretending to be amazon.com because if it was right they would have had to spoof
a vericine certificate and in order to do that they would have required vericine's private key
and that's typically not possible so you've authenticated the server as actually being amazon.com
and at this point you can also trust the contents of that certificate including the most important
information which is that public key belonging to actually amazon.com now the next step is pretty
important and you need to remember this it is you the client you the browser that will create
symmetric session keys with the functionality that's built into your browser and ssl you are going
to create symmetric session keys that you will encrypt now with what you can trust which is amazon's
public key so you will encrypt those keys that you created and send them back to amazon encrypted
in amazon's public key which now requires amazon to use their private key which no one else has
at which point they will have the same symmetric keys that you created so now any further
communications between you and amazon back and forth in both directions will be protected using
those symmetric keys that you created and that amazon was able to decrypt with their private key
that no one else has so now you can be pretty comfortable in sending your credit card numbers
any personal information anything else that requires security is going to be protected ultimately
using symmetric key cryptography but we used a a symmetric process to exchange those keys and that's
basically what ssl slash tls is it's a hybrid product that uses both symmetric and asymmetric key
cryptography to ultimately establish a very secure connection between you and again it doesn't
matter where you are and that secure server at the other end now one of the other things that
you need to remember here is that in our case we authenticated the server because you obviously
want to know that you've connected to amazon.com so there's always a need to authenticate the server
now you may see questions that ask does ssl slash tls support mutual authentication and the answer
to that is yes it is built in to ssl and tls that if there was a need you can also authenticate
the client what it would require is a client to have a certificate that would be sent to the server
in step number one when you send that client hello message you would also send your certificate
that the server in this case would be able to decrypt and trust and authenticate the client
so the answer to whether ssl supports mutual authentication is yes it's not normally required
because for what mostly happens across the web there's always a need to authenticate the server
but there may not be a need to authenticate the client as an example in this case amazon doesn't
care where you are whether you're at home or at the office or at Starbucks or in Bora Bora doesn't
matter right the amazon servers in this case don't care where you are so there's no need to authenticate
the client but if there was ssl has it built in that we can actually do that it requires
certificates at the client level that are sent to the server